demande quand même la vie de jeunes
verts de fonder
alors nous rejoignent et alors je vous
jure que ce n'est pas de notre fait le
seul responsable de ce de cet
accoutrement
désormais c'est à côté interros donc tu
es content de voir ça vous va bien
ouais au plus près que jamais se trouver
un peu la voix alors allez-y vous fait
oui passent leur temps à montrer leur
sens plastique et leur free free et vous
dire que c'est mélenchon bt une zone
très bon comme ça ou pas joué le jeu
quoi il demanderait mais votre voix
parce que j'écoute et honneurs du court
que je tends régie et j'ai pas que vous
écoutiez démission de ses biens comme
c'est très bien vous écoutez l'émission
parce que bientôt on la regardera la
maison délirer c'est très simple
3 je suis même content en étant jeune
bien parce que je partage était besoin
d'éviter dessus je trouve que
aujourd'hui j'ai moins aimé que ce que
tu as dit que tu étais c'est un
spectacle c'est pas un spectacle c'est
de voir des filles défiler en maillot de
bain et ensuite de les interviewer on
les a passées pour les imbéciles pour
lendemain se [ __ ] d'elle dans la tête
et messieurs j'ai vu quand je les
regarde je pas féministe alors je trouve
que j'étais s'est arrêtée un show de
cauet n'a eu guère jusqu'au bonnet jean
pierre foucault très bien que c'est
entre lui jamais de faire passer les
miches pour des imbéciles
c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui à fond
tout leur pose la question d'un ghetto
et moi ça veut je veux devenir de sauver
les jeux pour les connaître on demande
ce que tu as envie de toi tu vas
n'importe quel entretien on te demande
que cette envie de faire dans la vie qui
est super c'est normal ils posent des
questions bref me dire que tu attends
pas qu'elle dérape comme tout le monde
et comme une aberration non non bon we
were pierre foucault